[Music]
we're gonna go to anna in virginia beach
hey anna welcome to the show
hi guys thank you so much for taking my
call absolutely how can we help
i am in a situation with my father who
took out a parent plus loan for not only
me but both my other siblings as well
and there's a total of about two hundred
thousand dollars
in debt
yeah and and just his name
um it doesn't seem to be a worry for him
but this has been something that is
constantly on my mind since i worked
hard to get myself out of my own debt
and my name and now with the
um you know the government starting to
uh start loan payments again at the end
of january it's really uh been a
stressful factor for me
and what's making it stressful for you
the fact that he he's gonna be burdened
with this
well uh
i never knew that
there was no discussion between me and
him uh when i went to college
that he was going to do this parent plus
loan and that i would owe him this money
so after i graduated college he was like
by the way you owe me 65 000
wow
wow um
right and so um
past couple years i've been sending him
you know venmo payments towards it
and you know ever since the the shutdown
and they stopped taking payments we
haven't
tried to do anything with it but um
i i don't think it's right that i owe
him that money when we never had that
discussion but i'm i'm torn because
um thankfully i am able to actually pay
that off tomorrow if
i you know i prayed about it and that's
what god tells me to do but i'm not
having that
mindset i feel like this is like i was
taken advantage of you know i was only
17 or 18 years old and you know my
father put me in this very difficult
position
very much so and sadly anna you know
your story is
is common i hear this a lot even i even
had a friend and they went to go apply
for a mortgage and she had no clue and
it came up she was like wait what
um so it is sadly something that that
does happen have you talked to him about
this what shell's relationship like
it's
it's strained um he he left my family
when i was 12 years old but you know we
try to
we tried to mend that relationship but
there's definitely some um
you know anger still and resentment
toward like with us mostly on my end but
even more so because i have this
financial uh burden with him even though
it's not legally tied to me i feel you
know morally like i need to help him out
with this since he's in you know with my
siblings 200 000 debt i
he he can't pay that off and i don't
want my father to go bankrupt so
um
the conversation really always ends up
in a screaming match because
i care more about it than he does he's
on the public loan forgiveness program
so in his mind after you know the 120
payments the rest will be forgiven even
if the interest is capitalized
but that means seven more years of me
being financially tied to my father and
i i don't know if i can do that or not
yeah this sounds like an emotional and
relational decision more than a
financial one for you you have the money
to pay it off
i do but it would be all of me and my
husband's savings
including your emergency fund or is this
outside of that
outside of that okay
i mean to me i know you can put a price
on it and say yeah that's 65 000 in
savings but to have that weight
off of your shoulders out of your life
and to at least resolve your end of this
relationship and to be able to let go of
that
i'm weighing those options going i'm i
may just pay this and be done with it
because right now it feels like it's
weighing on you maybe even more than him
well the thing is to anna you're not
going to be able to control him right so
he could sit on this like you're saying
for seven more years or even if
something happens with the loan
forgiveness and it's not forgiven even
for like it and so it there is a level
of accountability he has to have that
you can't have for him that he was an
adult when he signed this up and
um
and as harsh as that sounds it's true
i'm like he he signed this so
he knew what he was getting himself into
whether he truly could like you know
pace out the entire future of his life
no but he's one that's so so that
responsibility is not on you but your
name and education not name but your
education and your experience is still
tied in a relational aspect back to this
alone so i
and i hate it cause i'm like man i know
you worked hard you're you have
savings in the bank and all of it but
but there is this
level of just
as john delano would say just mental
health of just
not having the stress not having the
relational strain and the fact that it
was your education even though i know
you were 17 and there was a lot of
manipulation in it and you didn't know
about it all of that
but there is something that you could
say okay i'm gonna i am gonna pay this
because it's worth me having peace at
night it's worth me not stressing
about my dad it's it's worth cutting the
ties is basically what it feels like and
this you're still tied to him
is the feeling i'm getting from you on
this call is that correct
yeah it's correct and i i guess my other
concern is how do i
how do i actually give my father that
amount in in trust that he's actually
going to use that large sum of money and
pay off
my my portion of the loan since they're
all consolidated so i don't i don't
really know how that works
well it would be
yeah obviously in good faith that he
would but you're not legally tied
to this loan and so for you this is a
moral
type decision it's not a legal financial
decision it is
hey i'm giving you this money to pay off
my loan and i'm done
you can't come back to me anymore for
anything i have i've paid my end of the
deal which
sucks because i didn't even know i had
to the end of the deal until after
college um but i'm gonna do this so that
i can i can have breathing room and and
and this stress be off me and then at
that point it is his responsibility and
up to him
but i think from your end to the deal of
you making this decision again it's not
um from a legal standpoint it really is
from an emotional standpoint do you
think if you had the conversation with
him and you sat down with him said hey i
want to pay this off would he be open to
that
what would that turn into
i think he would be i he's totally fine
with living in this debt and i i believe
based off
his
you know expenses that i see that he's
okay with putting himself more in debt
and i you know that's
basically more than half of america
being okay with that kind of mindset but
um
i i think he'd be okay with it i think
he wouldn't understand it and he would
try to convince me just to do the
payments to do the public loan
forgiveness thing
but like you guys said i mean we have no
idea what would happen in seven years um
you know he tries to also convince me
that maybe
the bonding administration will fall
through and they will give money towards
you know student debt and stuff like
that but i'm i don't plan on holding my
breath for that to happen well and i and
as we're talking about this anna
uh there is a part of me that would be a
little bit like gosh i don't want 65 i
don't want to enable him with 65 000
through like a video right like uh there
would have to be i would want to see on
a computer
transferring the money train you know
what i mean because i'm like i don't
want to hand him 65 000 of cash because
i think if you can get on the same page
and he's willing to allow the 65 000 to
be paid you sit with him and you guys do
this thing together and that way you can
see it happen you're on the same page
and there's this nice
clean
a clean break in a sense if this
relationship isn't going to be sorted
out but who knows there could be
redemption at the end of the story
so it's your job to just do what you can
and control what you can control but you
need to let go of this